Chef
Ecoute juste pour voir la cérémonie
[musique]
Bonjour je suis
Lee Jung-jae, un acteur en Corée
pas voir
Ah, ces jours-ci, il y a beaucoup de jeux de calmar
Je suis aussi un acteur connu.
Oh maintenant la chasse
Scénario diabolique 1
ah
En tant que Lee Jung-jae, je suis avec Khan 4
[musique]
ah
Je suppose qu'il y a plusieurs raisons
4 L'un d'eux est le changement de génération
Très intelligent, très averti à trois saveurs
un
Comme la génération aussi a changé, c'était très bien
Les films commencent à parler plus
C'est pareil et encore euh je l'ai déjà
Je travaille depuis 30 ans maintenant
De grands changements en 10 ans en Corée k
Salaire en pensant qu'il y avait du contenu
pendant
maintenant
Plus d'empathie avec les gens du monde entier
parce que le contenu
ah
Quel est l'âge d'or en ce moment ?
Je pense
Pour nous, cet âge d'or est maintenant
Je veux commencer un peu, et encore
Encore une génération plus jeune que nous
Maintenant sur le marché du contenu k
Comment as-tu pu entrer avec de l'eau ?
Cette jeune génération est différente de nous
idée et une autre
Oh, j'ai un pouvoir expressif, alors
Maintenant plus que la narration douée
Le contenu k que nous créons, nous aussi
Nous attendons et nous sommes très excités
ah
Je suis en train de penser
[musique]
en fait
Le jeu défini dans le scénario est de 6 s
Le set de jeu est arrivé.
Oh, comment cet ensemble a-t-il été construit?
comment l'environnement est décoré aussi
J'étais curieux, mais la première fleur de mucus
Il a fleuri. Quand j'ai vu le décor, c'était très
Ce qui m'a surpris, c'est la taille et
C'est ainsi que l'Iran et
beaucoup de gens ensemble dans une direction
Regarde-moi m'enfuir
c'est
Geunyoung
pas d'émission de télévision 5 comme certains gros
Les beaux-arts comme regarder une exposition
J'avais l'impression de regarder une exposition.
c'était très impressionnant
La première fleur d'hibiscus a fleuri
Je l'ai écrit après le tournage, mais quand j'ai fait mon premier tournage
Le réactionnaire Kim Il-tae a dit ceci
quelquechose d'énorme
euh
Il semble provoquer une réflexion, c'est génial
Quel genre de sensibilités éveillent #2
J'ai dit ça ressemble à ça
Beaucoup de gens dans le monde
Oh, amusez-vous et aimez-le
je ne savais pas
[musique]
verbe réellement arriver
En fait, ce n'est probablement pas le cas.
Aggs remuer trop faire 9
Le réalisateur travaille dur en ce moment, et il
quelque chose dans le processus
Oh, pour moi, d'une certaine manière, la moitié de ça
Pouvez-vous me donner un indice que le club est en cours d'écriture?
C'est la loi, mais vous ne le dites pas du tout.
Je ne suis pas sûr, donc je suis un peu curieux
Si vous savez un peu, s'il vous plaît venez plus tôt
Je pense que je peux me préparer
Je parle de 1, donc ma femme l'a commandé.
Eh bien encore une fois inoubliable
Oh, le premier voisin directeur du robinet avait 4 ans
et encore
tellement à la fin
merci de m'avoir longuement applaudi
Oh, ceux dans la relation
Je n'arrive pas à oublier
afuser
Bien sûr maintenant
Cannes, qui a invité mon film à
personnes impliquées
Je suis si heureux de dire bonjour
Et encore pendant cette période
Une photo prise avec Marion Cotillard
même
oh je suis si heureux
eww
Ah ah ah ah